what's going on guys welcome to another
python mathematics and finance
indicators video
this video we're going to be talking
about the gopala krishnan range
index otherwise known as gapo and that's
what i'm going to call it for the rest
of this video
the gapo is intended to measure the
volatility in a stock and it doesn't
incorporate volume so
you can think what you want about that
the only reason i
throw that in there is that sometimes
either your volume information isn't
included or you might not want to use
volume or you might want to maybe
add volume to the equation and make it
that much better
but it's kind of neat when you can have
an indicator that mimics volume yet does
not use
uh volume the calculation for the gapo
indicators
is basically going to be the logarithm
of the highest high for whatever time
frame you're considering minus the
lowest low for whatever time frame
you're considering
then you're going to do that divided by
the logarithm of that time frame
so with that let's go ahead and look at
an example of the scapo indicator before
we get into actually programming it
so here's our charting application if
you want to know more about it
uh check out our python charting
application tutorial video series
what so we're going to look at ebay and
so here we have ebay
and down here we've got the gappo 14 for
ebay
um actually uh nevermind i thought i had
changed it but no this is indeed the gap
of 14.
uh so here's an example of the
gap out here and as you can see so as
you know the volatility here
in theory is going up you can not only
see this in the chart
price but you can see in the volume
where volume really spikes up there and
price falls
sure enough the gap is pretty high again
here as it's very volatile
falling it goes up and then as it's
rising you can see the gapo goes up
and then uh where you've got more of
like a controlled like here's a spike
rise and here's a spike rise both times
you see the gap spike up
uh then you've got more of a controlled
steady rise without too much change and
it's not so crazy
and then here you you could say that
price is going up down up down up down
up down
but for the most part it's relatively
stable and it's a little up down a
little process and as you can see here
the gappo kind of like levels out so
with that let's look at another
uh gap indicator let's look at something
like uh tesla would be a good one where
it like kind of flat line
and then it went way up and then it's
been going way down
uh yeah it's a pretty good one so here's
tesla
and as you can see i mean it's
relatively stable here and then the
price starts
really rising and so the gappo indicator
goes way up right
and then it starts really falling and
sure enough the gap stays up right
because the idea of the gapo isn't
really
for trend at all it's volatility and
here's a great example of it matching
volume
pretty well where you know trade volume
is pretty low it's stable it's low and
stable here and then it spikes up here
with trade volume
and price as it you know gains
popularity or whatever
uh and really the gambo indicator
is like pretty much right on par with
the volume here
and then as you know the actual stock
starts trending down the rsi starts
trending down but the gap is still there
because it's obvious
it's volatility only so it's pretty
interesting indicator actually
um it's just another one of those i
actually quite like the indicators that
measure volatility without using volume
i think it's pretty cool
um obviously it's it's fairly simple i
mean the stock price itself measures
volatility usually without volume but
still
i like the indicators that do it's just
kind of like a neat out of the
or like out of the box method
uh for doing it so anyways that's the
gapo indicator in the next video what
we're going to be doing is
actually programming the gapo indicator
in python and then the video after that
we'll plot it up
just like this in this charting
application so if that sounds
interesting to you guys stay tuned to
the next video as always thanks for
watching